Je diverser, desto besser:
Das sollte für jede Gruppe gelten,
die einen Lerndatensatz für ein
KI-Training zusammenstellt.
Denn: Kommt eine
Sichtweise nicht vor,
entstehen Fehler.
Das berichten auch
die Forschungsgruppen der
IT-Universität Kopenhagen.
Hassrede zu erkennen,
ist schwierig, denn
manchmal ist es nur eine
Minderheit, eine bestimmte Gruppe
von Menschen, die
sie erkennen kann.
Wir haben beobachtet, dass es Fälle gab,
wo sich alle einig waren –
alle bis auf eine Person.
Zum Beispiel gab es eine Muslima,
und sie hat manche Worte erkannt,
mit denen immer abfällig
über Muslime gesprochen wurde.
Die anderen kannten die gar nicht.
Ist eine Gruppe
nicht repräsentiert, entwickelt
die KI Vorurteile.
Dazu kommt:
Eine KI lernt ständig weiter.
Wenn also im Netz einige Gruppen
weniger Wortmeldungen haben als der
Rest, denkt die KI, deren
Meinungen seien Minderheitsmeinungen.
Zum Beispiel in den
virtuellen Räumen, in denen es viel
Frauenfeindlichkeit gibt, melden
sich Frauen natürlich
weniger zu Wort.
Die KI denkt dann, dass Ansichten
wie geschlechtergerechte Bezahlung
extremistisch seien, weil diese
Ansichten eben dort kaum vorkommen.
Deswegen arbeitet eine
Forschungsgruppe der IT-Universität
an einer KI, die alle
Menschen online fair behandelt.
Ein Algorithmus soll Hassrede
im Netz erkennen, ohne dabei eine
bestimmte Gruppe zu diskriminieren.
Doch das ist nicht leicht:
Inhalte im Netz sind oft nicht
eindeutig. Schlagworte für das
Training dieser KI zu
erstellen, ist schwierig.
Ein Beispiel könnte hier sein:
„Ich hasse alle Dänen.“ Wir haben
hier eine Liste mit Identitäten.
Dänen, englische Menschen – das
kann alles Mögliche sein.
Und dann vergeben wir
verschiedene Kategorien:
Ist das verletzend gegenüber
einer bestimmten Identität?
Und in welche Richtung geht es?
Ist es allgemein? Oder geht es
um eine bestimmte Person? Um mich?
Bis der Algorithmus
fertig entwickelt ist,
wird es noch einige Monate dauern.
Firmen wie Facebook
könnten in Zukunft von
solchen Modellen profitieren.